What if I told you,
we discovered an alien species with an
adaptable body,
advanced intelligence and astounding
camouflage skills, enter the octopus.
Wait, what did you think I was talking about? Right.
Could these slithery ocean dwellers be from outer
space?
Where did they come from and how did they get to
earth? This is what if,
and here's what would happen if octopuses are aliens from outer
space. All right.
It's time to put your tin foil helmet on because today we're getting
a little out there.
Octopuses are as cool as they are mysterious.
So mysterious that some scientists are putting the theory forward,
that they aren't even from our planet.
Octopuses are incredibly intelligent creatures and are
masters of disguises.
They can use their color changing cells to blend in with the environment,
move their arms,
to impersonate other ocean species and are excellent problem
solvers.
So what if they're so smart that they've pulled a fast one on
all of us?
What if they're really aliens and have only convinced us that they
originated here on earth? It's genetics.
Absolutely. Unearthly.
The theory goes that 500 million years ago, an icy media,
right? Carrying an alien life form fell to earth.
This life form fertilized octopus, eggs,
mind blown case closed. Thanks for watching.
Be sure to like and subscribe. Okay. Can see you're skeptical.
So let's go a little deeper.
You're probably asking how the heck is an alien life form going to survive in
the cold reaches of space before getting to earth. Well,
here's the thing microbes such as those seen in bacteria are
extremely tough.
Microbes can thrive in temperatures as low as minus 18 degrees
and can even be preserved in liquid nitrogen at minus
196 degrees.
This means that they couldn't care less about the extreme pressures of space.
And in theory could float around for billions of years before
hitting a planet.
But if the octopus did crash land on earth 500 million
years ago, where did it come? Well,
we know the octopus is a water creature, so let's start there.
Our bet is Europa. One of Jupiter's moons.
Europa has an icy exterior and might have a liquid ocean underneath
seems like a cozy space for an interplanetary octopus, right?
Could a massive asteroid have smashed into Europa 500 million years
ago, resulting in huge chunks of debris being torn out into space.
And if so, could some of that debris have held octopus eggs in it?
The answer is maybe call me Fox Mulder because I
want to believe,
but this is some really far out stuff is calling an
octopus, an alien. The only way to explain them. I mean,
we have plenty of weird creatures on earth without extra terrestrial
interference. In 2015,
scientists were able to map the genome of the octopus.
Did they find some surprises? Sure they did, but an alien origin story.
Wasn't one of them the most significant discovery was that their genes
split off from squids about 135 million years ago,
which is long after they allegedly crashed into earth.
So could octopuses really be from outer space? Well,
it's a fascinating theory, but as of today,
it doesn't have the science to back it up.
And even though they're not from outer space,
it doesn't mean we can't still learn from them,
but don't take our word for it.
Ask award-winning environmental journalists and the director of the documentary,
my octopus teacher PIPA, girlish. Join us on.
What if discussed to take a deeper dive into the world of these
fascinating creatures?
[Inaudible].